so that we are producing at home the
medicines and equipment and everything
else that we need to protect the
public's health and I've been talking
about this for a long time that process
has already started it started long
before we ever knew about this we want
to make certain things at home we want
to be doing our manufacturing at home
it's not only done in China it's done in
many other places including Ireland and
a lot of places make our different drugs
and things that we need so badly and
it's not good to be dealing with one or
two or three countries and we do very
little at home and we're going to start
doing it at home and we've been talking
about that for a long time and a lot of
the drug companies because of what we've
done in terms of incentives and taxes
they're heading back here anyway
the coronavirus shows the importance of
bringing all of that manufacturing back
to America and we will have that started
it's already started frankly it started
about a year ago the white house
coronavirus task force led by Vice
President Mike Pence has been meeting
daily in coordinating closely with the
state and local governments Mike had a
call today with 53 governors and I heard
it was a very good call and everybody is
very well coordinated and the governor's
and the states all of them I can't think
of an exception they've been really
working closely with us it's been it's
been a very good very good relationship
we will confront this challenge together
and we will continue to do exactly what
we're doing and we're going to be very
successful a lot of things are happening
a lot of very exciting things are
happening and they're happening very
rapidly so with that I'd like to
introduce Mike and you can say a little
bit as to your calls and some of the
things that have happened today
well thank you mr. president and the
White House Corona task force will be
meeting again this afternoon but as you
mentioned earlier today your direction
we hosted a video and telephone
conference called with 53 governors as
the president said many times we're all
in this together and today's meeting is
a reflection of the fact that this
president for the one team in America
that's going to address the corona virus
in this country and I'm grateful for
these leaders of the nation's top
pharmaceutical companies to come in to
speak to us about the development of
vaccines but also the development of
therapeutic medications that can be
available in the short-term and we're
grateful for your participation the
president will also be a traveling
tomorrow to the National Institute of
Health
CDC before the week is out and we will
be meeting with leaders of the airline
industry will be meeting with with
leaders of the cruise line industry and
we welcome the partnership with industry
in this country as we as we work out the
president's top priority which is the
health and safety and well-being of the
American people
let me also mr. president extend my
welcome to dr. deborah birx is one of
the one of the leading experts in
infectious diseases in the world she has
served in the uniform of the United
States she has served in multiple
administrations and she's going to be
our right arm here as as we implement
that your vision for putting the health
and safety and well-being of the
American people first so with that mr.
president I know secretary azar has a
few thoughts and and look forward to the
meeting
and Alex maybe you can give a little
update and then we'll go around the room
and people can introduce themselves if
that's okay Thank You mr. president mr.
vice president so we continue to see
cases here in the United States as you
know we tragically have experienced
several more deaths reported today and
our condolences go out to their families
of course that's why the president's
leading this whole of government
response at the direction of the vice
president we're here working with the
pharmaceutical company leaders on three
key issues how do we speed vaccines how
do we speed therapeutics and what are
the supply chain challenges that we may
be facing for pharmaceutical products
here in the United States with regard to
with regard to therapeutics and vaccines
we want to know how we can not get in
their way but rather speed that
development process along I want to make
sure that they all know that we've got
Commissioner Hahn here from the FDA and
this is all in the context of emergency
powers emergency use authorization Xand
the president will be asking you how
could we make it faster how can we make
anything faster how can we challenge
some of those normal Pharma timelines
that can be a little slow and
bureaucratic what could we do to speed
that along given the nature of this
emergency and be a good partner with you
in making that happen especially once we
get the emergency supplemental passed by
Congress in the next week or so so with
that said mr. president thank you very
much and supplemental is moving along
very rapidly everyone wants to get that
done moving more quickly Emma please
Emma warms live from GlaxoSmithKline
first of all I'd like to really say how
much we welcome the leadership mr.
president of this task force to NIH and
Barda and recognize the very substantial
efforts that have already been made by
the administration to protect people
here in the US as a science led company
with a very large including
manufacturing presence here we know we
have a responsibility and a vital role
to play and our priority is to make sure
we make available as part of this one
or pandemic adjuvant technology
available to any company with a high
highly promising vaccine because this
new technology could make these other
vaccines either bring more efficacy or
indeed allow them to be antigen sparing
which means we could protect more people
which is obviously incredibly important
as we're trying to work a patient and at
scale we've already announced two
collaborations and hope to announce more
we're also ready to produce should the
US government require it a stockpile of
this adjuvant we know fighting over 19
requires a global efforts and the u.s.
is the vital leader endless and we're
absolutely committed to play our part
thank you very much
I'm Tony Fauci the director of the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases very pleased to be
on this task force which I think you're
gonna see is working extraordinarily
smoothly under the leadership with the
vice president and secretary azar and as
you know we're involved and that's the
reason why I am pleased to be within
this room with you all because we were
involved in the fundamental basic and
clinical research to develop
countermeasures in the form of
therapeutics and vaccines and I'm sure
I'll be working with many of you around
the room and it look forward to it Thank
You mr. president is very much
director CDC I also want to thank you
all for being here I want to extend that
there's anything CDC can also do as you
begin to try to evaluate some of your
fruits of your labor you know we're here
to make that what we have available to
help we're all we're all counting on the
new countermeasures to be in the arena
pretty quickly thank you please Thank
You mr. president sir vice president
thanks for having me here yeah and
there's Dan man atella CEO of cure back
we're a clinical stage biotech company
we use messenger RNA technology
optimized messenger RNA molecules once
injected into the body they instruct the
cells on how to make proteins for
instance we can use the mRNA technology
to trigger an immune response against
viruses or we can get the body to
increase its production of T cells for
cancer vaccines in this way qmn can make
potent prophylactic vaccines and cancer
treatments the technology also works
well to replace missing proteins so we
can also work in rare diseases one
strength of our technology is that we
can produce prophylactic vaccines using
a very low dose so for instance the
phase one rabies trial that we just
completed was done at a 1 microgram dose
so in other words a millionth of a gram
dose a very very tiny approach and so
more broadly our company focuses so this
year we have four programs in Phase one
clinical trials and the coronavirus
program will be the fifth program in
phase one we expect that the Phase one
program for rotavirus will start
beginning into our technology platform
is fast and it's agile we were the first
messenger RNA the company to have GMP
manufacturing we started in 2006
currently we have three large-scale G&P
facilities and we are up and running or
up and running now today we have a
fourth facility built and we're looking
for additional capex
with the machinery
there once we have that machinery in the
fourth building we can make hundreds of
millions of doses of the corona virus
vaccine so we're very excited about that
and they want to help there
additionally we have developed a
fully-automated production 50
machine this automated machine is part
of the collaboration with Sepi and
additionally with suppiy we are working
on the corona virus they have funded our
efforts to get the program and the
vaccine into phase 1 by June the key
point here being that we believe we can
develop the vaccines recovered 19 very
very quickly and we have the wherewithal
to manufacture it although we would like
some additional help on our largest GMP
facility again we appreciate the
opportunity to be here today thank you
very much John John Schreiber ahead
vaccine research fraud men developers
tend to be vaccine seventies been making
vaccines for over a hundred years and
we're for this project that we're
working with proprietary of recombinant
protein technology that makes the first
flu vaccine that's not an X based on
this technology it has the potential to
be applied very readily to kata bars
some early work done with SARS the
related virus was very promising we
intend to leverage that work so that we
can get to the clinic as soon as
possible well because we are a major you
know a flu vaccine producer with this
technology we have the ability to
produce a large amounts of vaccine we
predict depend upon the final
formulation a hundred to six hundred
million doses per year made in New York
and Pennsylvania which is where we make
most of our about 90% of our flu product
and we can do this without jeopardizing
our flu vaccine production importantly
because we know that's very important to
maintain that so mr. president we're
willing to do whatever it takes to work
with you in this administration the
collaboration we've had settled NIH and
with Barda who's co-sponsored my
research to make sure that we do what we
can to help with this problem
when do you think you could have the
vaccine when do you think you'd be able
to have it start producing it produce it
now the experiment a lot proteins take
somewhat longer than some of the other
technologies more exploratory but it's
approached if it does it works we think
we could be ready for the clinic getting
here and depending upon the nature of
how the epidemic goes or doesn't go you
know we would end with the help of the
agencies of this country you know
perhaps as few as said we are difficult
to predict mr. president knowing that a
vaccine has to be both safe and
efficacious because it's given to
healthy people thank you very much
we are no strangers to collaborating
with the administration we work with
secretary Jarvis booth Barda and we came
up with a cure for Ebola and we're very
proud of that that the vouchers group
was really instrumental in testing that
under unbelievable conditions in the
Congo and it didn't create quite as much
excitement because thank goodness it
didn't hit our shores but we can use the
exact same technology and we already
have we have a thousand antibodies that
are already sitting in dishes we're
screening them with selecting them we
anticipate afore goes well 200,000 doses
per month can come out of our Factory in
New York starting in August the unique
thing about our technology means you'd
be able to use a vaccine that earlier
depends on what we see how we work
closely with the FDA and which we will
do
the FDA has already reached out to us
but we've got to work close on that
process would be faster than Jones
the you explain why that would be well
so we make passive vex vaccine and
therapeutic therapeutic our drug will be
able to protect you whether or not
you're infected it'll protect you from
getting infected well if you are
infected
it would treat you and the we have just
taken processes that normally take years
literally years and we put an end to end
and now do them in weeks to months if
nobody else in the industry can do so
we're very excited to climb back once
again this is a combination of a vaccine
and
[Music]
a Nazi